it's time for screen junkies movie
fights god bless america everybody happy
July 5th
we are still partying it down making
America's birthday take him to the next
day hope you had a great 4th of July in
America and around the world welcome to
movie fights we have an awesome group of
competitors here and yeah it's gonna be
real star-spangled Edition first oh you
know this guy is one of the writers of
honest trailers you know him from SJ
news and he says he's got one of the
dumbest things he's ever undertaken
coming out gonna be dropping on the
internet shortly and soon follow me on
twitter keep up oh hell yeah Joestar
what's up pal what's up good to see you
buddy Oh next to Joe
this gentleman is one of the co-hosts of
the nerd if ascent podcast you can check
out his HIGHlarious comedy album
community college dropout that is
available online and he's an all-around
swell guy well can they find your comedy
album anywhere you could get albums you
can get it on iTunes you can get it on
Spotify you can get my title yep that
was I've pushed for that dudes in it's
on title Columbia House you can tape a
penny yes 80's 90's reference at
Columbia house and on the end you know
this very funny man he's America's
favorite Schmo and if you're going to be
a comic-con Friday night 10 p.m. at the
American comedy company in the Gaslamp
District mark headlines with special
guests like Joe star it's hosted by Ken
nap sock and Josh mokuba check that out
and go to Mark Ellis live.com promo code
Schmo Oh how's a mouthful and he just
knocks it so far out of the park you
wrote it down perfectly for me mark oh
man thank you JT my assistant for
writing that down
just like I taught him yeah Comic Con is
gonna be a whole lot of fun so you guys
doing some stand-up there
I love the setup here today because you
look like the owner of the Texans Bob
McNair looks like your punk ass son who
doesn't really like his dad but still
wants the support America she's wearing
the colors I like Rocky's shittiest son
my boy hates fishing but he's gonna wear
the star subscribe geez movie fights
will be decided by three judges myself
Dan Merle and Danielle Radford who was
the conduit of the people let's go to
the damn cam dad I would like to join
you particularly in hoping that our
international viewers had a fantastic
July 4th you know I'm just like for them
it was just Wednesday I hope you had a
great Wednesday yeah sure the United
States
you know everyone can have a great
Independence Day is no longer just an
American holiday but the digital world
said in one collective voice we will not
go quietly into the night thank you Bill
Pullman no Radford tell us what you're
up to over there oh hi so today is gonna
be another one of those days where I
have to have my own opinion about wake
up so I thought you go to limp Biskit oh
I wish you guys could see a full body
shot of Joestar I'm very excited when
you get to see it later not even
specifically for now just in general
yeah in general I mean yeah so today is
one of those days where I have my own
opinions if there is fact-checking than
they need to help with I can for example
before the show we had a whole debate
about who did the white men can't jump
theme song I said it was boys to men it
is actually a group no one has ever
heard of called riff boys to men did
symphony easy rich man yeah you know
they got that his song do you know
what was the course of that on how our
game works the first fighter to get four
points wins we have three regular round
questions and then we hit the speed
round and someone's up three oh go and
the speed round still anybody's game
because you can come back in that speed
round we got tiebreakers and all that
good stuff fellas you ready to mix it up
that's right a little jte dropped that
sick-ass package
[Music]
nicely done jakey best packaging the
best yeah that every time I see that
it's like that was illegal in tournament
karate matches you can't kick anyone in
the face
what about any all-valley corrupt it's
really frustrating here is the first
question of the regular round what movie
character not that it needs replacement
but what movie character should replace
the Statue of Liberty
what movie character should replace the
Statue of Liberty let's say like you
know she was gonna retire guys covered
her in pink ooze and walked around the
city and then she something bad a step
up started rusting I think we I think
it's I think we are due for a new Lady
Liberty there you know
we'll start with Joe Starkel there was
one movie character that came to mind
for me when trying to decide who should
replace the Statue of Liberty and I've
heard that he's a bad mother shut your
mouth hey I'm talking about shaft John
shaft
there's the man yeah this is a guy who
will do anything for his brother and
anything for his community and I think
he would make a pretty slick-looking
dare I say sexy cool Statue of Liberty
John shaft
shut your mouth all right John shaft the
Richard Roundtree original rocket with
the Sam Jackson shaft or nitric
Roundtree okay if he my duty to get with
that booty you know I took this into
consideration because I think about what
do I think about when I see the Statue
of Liberty I'm not there has to be some
welcoming parade to fin like I always
looked at the Statue of Liberty growing
up like Oh she'll come to life if she
has to to protect us right and destroy
us and that's why my pick is Ripley from
alien just because she has the strength
and beauty that that that I think we
should be seeing from you know the
distance and taking pictures in front of
with our families and also you know I
felt like we needed you know
I don't want to you know mix it up too
much I want to leave it as a woman I
don't want to take away one more thing
for women okay I didn't see that as an
opportunity to snatch one more thing for
women in this climate No No thank you
who's your pick all right if he pro him
in pro ripley mark my pitches is newt
who ripley adopted no is somebody who
represents the best of America and
indeed the world because how let's not
forget the Statue of Liberty was a
president from our good friends in
France the Statue of Liberty
it's an American symbol but I think that
it's a symbol to the world as well hey
you can come here and you can be safe
and nobody represents the interest of
Earth the world and America better than
somebody who is spirited in commerce who
had a background in war mongering but
turned his life around for the
betterment of humanity and that is Tony
Stark Tony Stark should be the new
Statue of Liberty Tony Stark is somebody
who became a superhero Iron Man and he
learned a moral core value along the way
and that is that we need to protect not
just Americans not just people who may
have the same citizenship as us but
people all around the world who can't
defend themselves that's the spirit of
the Statue of Liberty and that's the
spirit of Tony Stark really all the
Avengers but you can just change that a
on his tower to be America and indeed a
symbol for all the world
all right marquel is getting pretty raw
there let's mix it up everybody you guys
know who hates Tony Stark aside from
Avengers fans everyone else in the world
including this country every time Tony
Stark comes around hey Tony you killed
my son hey Tony you drop's likova out of
the sky Tony Stark is the worst possible
symbol for the statue of liberals mark
Alyn you had the choice of picking the
most American Avenger and you're like
nah I'm gonna go with Elon Musk
the week we're going into the future
where you guys could not get your brains
around the fact that oh yeah shaft is a
nice representative of New York and
Ellen Ripley why would you have her be
the statue when she never spends any
time on earth she's literally going to
other galaxies because she'd rather be
anywhere else than the United States of
America is in the heart for one thing my
calluses here because where I take her
she took the United States of America
yeah on board a space freighter yep and
fought an alien exactly god bless
america
lost has to ship me if I may ask to chef
just being representation I just want to
let you know that you are heavily
defending if he's look here's the thing
yes shaft is a strong representation of
New York but New York's the gateway man
New York's the melting pot that's what
it's all about and furthermore this is a
man who's all about his community I
think everyone could stand up and be a
shaft for their individual community
what are we if not a collection of
melting pot communities also here's the
thing with Ripley it's a little it's
it's a little aggressive it's a little
violent I I might you know she is the
statue she's got the flamethrower that's
a weird thing to roll up to whereas when
you roll up to the John shaft Statue of
Liberty what are you here when you're on
that boat and you're looking you're
looking inspired and then you should
start to hear
okay so now this is a bicycle shoes let
me ask you one dope is your trip to
America now that the shaft music is
playing
look everyone everyone at the Port
Authority is real chill now is that
Isaac Hayes's pump I got just a
completely different experience I got
one question for you because you came at
the flamethrower let me ask you is is
the Statue of Liberty the first thing
you see when you go into Canada or is it
the first thing you see we coming in
America because here in America I think
we're all about flamethrowers I think a
whole bunch of bit people spent way too
much money on flamethrowers from Elon
Musk
it's about plasma beams we're awesome
rocket pack we're also about the future
of technology that's why Tony Stark
not at all see Alan Ridley once again
just aside from the fact that you guys
are trying to rip one more thing from
women this is this is because Tony Stark
doesn't have a vagina does a well-placed
replacement for the Statue of Liberty no
it's great in a toga is one of these
private Robert Downey jr. is probably
worn a toga probably beaten won from
being way too drunk yeah it's not a good
it's not a good role model whereas look
like shaft is taken down drug dealers
since he's taken down corporate greed
that's the America I want to go this is
drug dealers and this is aliens yes she
isn't in America much because that's the
sacrifice that she's willing to make to
protect not only the country but the
world she's also a second inning pond of
a corporate entity yeah but that's super
American the best case is that she gets
impregnated by an alien and then she
makes it back to earth somehow and then
we have zero morphs all over the place
so unless do you want the Statue of
Liberty how to be a xenomorph then I
think you stay away from the aliens
franchise and as far as chap goes it's a
cute local story it's nice and you're
like you said it's international he went
to Africa mr. Murray thank you he's a
Globetrotter representative of how
America is a freedom binge rocket ship
for the rest of the world you can come
here and Tony Stark my characters
failures are public unlike unlike shaft
and unlike Ellen Ripley why because
Ellen Ripley failed in space so this
disavow
anything she's ever done and Richard
Brown tree is chef I'm sure he's done
bad things in his life but nobody cares
why because nobody cares about chef the
same way they care about the MCU you
cannot deny how popular of a character
Tony Stark is he is world's more popular
than if you're one of these twos this is
your final is here all about popularity
America is all about Commerce and it's
all about learning from your mistakes
and doing the right thing with
technology something that neither these
other two examples have any of Joe go
ahead and put a button on your argument
Logan Paul is popular but I don't want
them representing us you know in that
Harbor that's not a good evening as a
guy living in a mansion in Malibu
whereas John shaft is a blue-collar man
of the people you say you can't
recognize John shaft from a sea of
Americans good
that's the symbol that I want up there
just a cool as hell looks good on a
leather jacket could be you could be you
could be me could be howling that hat
just welcoming you to America in the
chillest way possible thank you Joe if
II look I'm and just say it like this
elemental he touches on all the
cornerstones of America we got corporate
greed and we got someone seeking asylum
like the Xenomorphs who you which you're
weird right leaning rhetoric saying all
these xenomorphs rump rosy nose and I
think we need to fight but not only that
she represents the love for weapons and
you're saying that she isn't about
technology when most of her life is in a
spaceship she is more Pro Tech now my
question is there is there a xenomorph
as part of the statue I imagine she's
holding a flamethrower in one arm in a
baby Zeno in the other and it says give
me your poor give me your hungry too
ma'am
all right Wow okay what a battle what a
throwdown
dan Murrow factuality 'he's none great
xenomorphs do in fact have two mouths oh
man thing is as easy as hill wrote the
white men can't jump fail yeah I wish
that was it come on Howard so three
vastly different characters here and
strong arguments across the board Jo and
inspiring with just playing that
everyman card of shaft representing
American values and dreams but is he
more just a New York character does he
have the appeal ripley the the strength
the beauty the femininity tony stark the
the corporate greed but turning his life
around you know what I gotta say mark
when you said freedom Bryn's rocketship
and like I just I don't even know what
that combination of words means but
inspire me and I gave you the point but
then I pulled it back and if he putting
that xenomorph in the Statue and just
like tying everything together with a
flamethrower that is an image that I
will never take out of my head I will
never lose if you get my point
thank you Dan the spike went many ways I
one point gave everyone at that table
the point surprised at Google right now
computer
I agreed it is important for America to
be open and welcome and and but I don't
know if I can endorse a 100 percent Pro
xenomorph agenda I just feel like they
they are opening the floodgates to very
destructive life you're also opening
people's chest very distressing
had been and evidence in previous alien
movies some Xenomorphs that were coming
in to start a business
[Laughter]
mainstream media I don't know between
Joe and Mark and I think that Tony Stark
while he does stand up for many of
what's great about America also
exemplifies the destructive tendencies
so I'm gonna have to go with the
crusader John shaft and my point goes to
Joe alright that's 1.4
it's one vote for Joe Daniel Radford man
yeah this was I definitely as amazing as
Ripley would be on there I even make it
maybe I am also a victim of mainstream
media and the way that they represent
Xenomorphs but it's just like I can't
have a country of chest bursters so
unfortunately if he knocked me out
although you did have some really great
arguments and the the argument that Joe
had about how Logan Paul is also popular
but he doesn't necessarily one on the
Statue of Liberty was one of the ones
that got me alone when he said everyone
else hates Tony and people just like a
free winner did just run up on him and
was like hey sudden-death so because of
that i have to go with joe joestar
yeah on my bingo i Logan pulled and now
we're waiting for a golden child
reference Joe is ahead one to zero to
zero
going into question number two all right
damn it
in honor of fourth of July here's
another patriotic question what's the
most kick-ass patriotic movie of all
time what is the most action-packed
patriotic movie okay this question on my
paper says kick-ass this one says
action-packed so
gasps action-packed movie of all time
and we're gonna start with player number
two iffy all right so you know it's very
easy to pick a movie that you know put
some America versus another country or
in some way shape or form but usually
the most kick-ass patriotic moves are
the ones where we pretend to be humble
include all other countries but then
America kicks the most ass yeah just why
I'm going with Pacific Rim so you have
all the countries come together with
their Yeager's and they're in there
stepping up to the plate to stop this
this force that no one else seems to
stop and guess who saves the day the
Americans and what's more American than
a white dude with his beautiful Asian
girlfriend maybe you know let's go right
out the gate
that's what I'm talking about we got big
bad monsters and we use a boat as a bat
and that's when I stood up in the
theater and clapped and I said sir can
you sit down you smell too much like the
wacky tabacky all right if he burned one
and watched Pacific Rim Marc Ellis what
do you like now we won't kick ass we
want action-packed then you look no
further than the best movie to watch on
the fourth of July really any other
holiday or really any other day of the
week and that is rocky for because rocky
Fork has both loads of great action when
you look at all the in the ring things
going on between Apollo Creed and Ivan
Drago within Rocky Balboa and Ivan Drago
and if that wasn't enough you want
kick-ass patriotic action you also have
not one not two three sports training
montages that go on throughout the
entire movie none of my competitors are
gonna offer you maybe even one sports
training montage
there's tons of weightlifting and
running and practicing in the gym
there's even beach frolicking from other
Rocky movies that's right they took all
the action and all the rocky franchise
up to that point and they combined it
into one small training sequence in a
movie that is filled start to finish
with great action this is the movie that
kicks the most ass it has the most
action and by the way it ended the Cold
War the Cold War why was it powering
more because there is no action and
rocky force said put up or shut up poo
or get off the toilet Cold War and rocky
four with all its action ended that dry
spell
all right I know Mark Ellis always loved
some good beach frolicking Joe he
absolutely does and God bless you for it
mark again I appreciate you guys are
here I'm gonna take it down a little bit
my movie is about it's a simple film
it's about a an immigrant that comes to
this country to follow his American
dream which is opening up a market in
New York City his own grocery store and
he runs afoul of a multicultural gang
which his nephew comes into town and
helped him defend I'm talking of course
about Jackie Chan's rumble in the Bronx
this movie start to finish is not only
just action-packed but just patriotic as
hell you've got this guy living the
American dream this is a guy Jackie
coming he's like hey you're ready to
meet your aunt and and he's like yeah
yeah yeah and he walks up to another
Chinese late he's like I'm so happy to
meet you and he's like no that's not
your aunt and he's his new aunt is this
black woman and he's a little stunned at
his uncle's like no no man welcome to
America she's a great woman this is
another just great melting pot immigrant
story and look I got to tell you on the
on the action front man I know that a
Sylvester Stallone sure does punch a
whole bunch and good for boxing but
Jackie Chan fights dudes with his whole
body and everything that's around him
the shirt off his back the the hammer on
the ground a box of cereal Jackie Chan
kicks so much ass this movie runs
circles around rocky 4 and it's also not
just a bunch of computer graphics oh man
write it out y'all mean this that's cute
I like you know the cereal boxes and all
that I imagine that looks looked real
cool when that came out in the 90s or
whatever but I'm talking about using a
boat as a bat which it looks like
garbage in five years oh man but right
now that's tight right now at this
moment that we're talking into these
mics it looks tight right now rumble in
the Bronx were like
I mean we got we got stuff like into the
badlands and we got we got other
high-tech kung fu movies Jackie Chavez
the goat don't get me wrong huh he is
truly the goat but he's not hitting
people with a boat so he's the goat but
there's no competition and rumble in the
Bronx it's basically Jackie Chan's show
something he just beats up a bunch of
known names where Rocky is going up and
get another great opponent they're
throwing punches back and forth plus you
have Apollo Creed plus you have Brigitte
Nielsen very intimidating plus you have
training sequences involving all of
these characters and whereas Pacific Rim
is a lot of dull slow lumbering let me
just slowly walk up to you juice let me
take my hang on you can go pee and get
popcorn and come back and I'll still be
walking towards a kaiju and by the way
why are kaiju is allowed into this
country in the first place because if he
made the Statue of Liberty Ellen Ripley
it might be slow and lumbering but
that's called realism franchise knows
nothing about you saw the robot that
your franchise produce trash patriotic
about an American robot sitting on the
sidelines while everyone else gets their
asses kicked on his behalf and then
running in and going save the day that
sucks and Mark I'm glad that you think
inspirational jogging constitutes action
let me tell you about Jackie Chan's
jogging scene and rumble in the Bronx
he's being chased for his life in a
parking garage and by the way he doesn't
spend this movie kicking everyone's ass
he spends a lot of it on it just like
rocky doesn't Rock you for he gets
chased by dirt biking through a parking
garage is getting his ass beat running
for his life it's an awesome awesome
sequence doing his own stunts no wires
no no safety net no man he's the dude if
you think it's exciting to beat people
up with your jacket or a cereal box or
an ordinary household appliance watch
Sly Stallone work out in a barn and
juxtapose it with Ivan Drago working out
in a futuristic gym facility complete
with steroids and jackée champ getting
to jog and get his ass beat on level
ground that's a walk in the park
compared
to Rocky Balboa who's single-handedly
climbed a 10,000 foot mountain that's
not jogging he climbed a 10,000 foot
mountain in one afternoon got up there
yelled Drago inspired us all oh and by
the way after that scene then we get one
of the most epic boxing clashes in
history it was so easy it was held on
Christmas Day and it was unsanctioned I
think we're finding out more just about
your internet kinks than we are about an
action-packed movie it's because you can
re-watch kick-ass over and over and over
again and the most kick-ass movie we're
not asking for patriotism here how we're
not asking for my movie just offers that
as icing on the cake of kick-ass action
Ramon the Bronx isn't also just fighting
its it there's badass vehicle sequences
he does this amazing like water ski
chase their speedboats at the end which
blows the face off one completely out of
the water so there you've got your kung
fu you've got your vehicle stunts you've
got he has to there's a dirt bike race
down an alley where he's like outrunning
the gang from Fast and the Furious
basically just on foot you've got a huge
variety of action as opposed to just
these weird little lumbering mechs with
Charlie Hunnam still learning how to
walk does anyone notice - Charlie Hunnam
like has a really different walk in
every movie like he still has a thing
that we keep forgetting when we're
constitute what makes kick-ass are the
stakes and what are the stakes in your
two moves what you lose a boxing match
and he doesn't come back to life just
because some white dude from the Bronx
beats a Russian as a matter of fact I
heard Putin watches that every night and
that's what fuels him to be as strong as
he is right now watches it every night
that's what fuels him listen the energy
yeah to be that's my take on rocky 4 in
your case what what if Jackie moved what
if Jackie Chan would have just moved to
LA where would have been way more chill
boom movie over Pacific Rim they had
nothing left to do left to do but to
pull themselves up by their robotic
bootstraps go underwater
in Pentecost he went down there and he
was like look look you're gonna have to
go down there you're gonna have to fight
these kind you you're gonna have to do
this and I believed him when he did that
speech in front of all those robots and
humans I was there and I was like this
is what America is all about man teaches
you Jesus as you're our final thoughts
and any anything else yeah look what
makes a patriotic movie is big stakes
big battles in huge speeches like said
movie Independence Day I'm like rocky or
rumble in the box you might have an epic
big ol nasty badass patriotic movie if
there's not those two things
epic fights and big speeches your moves
that neither thank you Fe do involve
vehicles of the future at the time
Rocky's driving a Lamborghini he's
looking in the rearview mirror thinking
about his past he's thinking about his
future action pack and then he fights
people in the end of the movie and you
talk about stakes how I think that when
we're looking at kick-ass movies that
are action-packed you want something to
fight for his rumble in the Bronx it's
just one guy getting his ass beat in the
Bronx and with Pacific Rim it's just
dystopian future and you never really
emotionally connect any of the
characters as they're slowly boringly
lumbering across to these equally boring
and slow lumbering huge monsters rocky 4
packs the most punch through definitely
the most punches thrown in Rocky four
and rocky 4 actually means something to
people these movies came and went and
rocky 4 has stayed in the public sight
guys the public lexicon more than
anything else why because it's got the
most action and it kicks the most ass
all right Joe give us your final thought
I mean look if you want to do a punch
count four minutes into rumble in the
Bronx Jackie Chan works out on a
practice dummy and throws more hand
strikes than Rocky does in that entire
movie in about 30 seconds this is this
movie has fantastic stakes it's about
family it's about keeping this this new
family's anchor their business alive
it's got
like chase sequences it's got smaller
fights it's got a big ridiculous
soundtrack Jackie Chan's the greatest of
all time in terms of choreographing
fights because not only they badass and
you're invested in how cool they are but
you're also he's also so good at selling
pain and I think that's another key on
what makes a good action movie I think
that's how you get into the guy said
that's why we love John McClane because
we saw the pain in space when he's
picking the glass out that's what John
McClane didn't work out later on when he
became a Superman everything Jackie Chan
does affects them and if you want
speeches it's not the longest speech in
the world but after he beats the crap
out of the bad guy gang in their own in
their own hideout it looks like the
weird Foot Clan gang hideout from the
first Ninja Turtles movie it's
ridiculous it's great he beats the crap
out of all these dudes and then just
says when we meet again I hope we won't
be fighting each other and I think
that's very that's patriotic as hell
that's optimistic that's American
optimism right there roaming the Bronx
all right time Dan Merle give us some
facts and please weigh in with your mark
reference rocky force single-handedly
ending the Cold War rocky 4 was released
in November of 1985 the Cold War's but
officially and until 19 any way that it
started the beginning of the end of a
couple years earlier in summer 1989
either way historically Rocky Ford not
acknowledged as the singular events that
brought the Cold War history is written
by the winners well see what history has
to say about rocky for other than that I
looked up the the the elevation on the
mountain that rocky ran up and ten
thousand feet actually it was filmed in
the Grand Tetons in Wyoming and the
highest peak is 13,000 feet so that
actually checks out as far as the
elevation that potentially goes I don't
know exactly around down to make it a
fair fight yeah Wow it's a different
mountain but absent the specific
information I have to give Marc a check
mark on the elevation for Rocky's
Mountain run all right you too Randy
toes
give us your thoughts on the battlefield
oh wow well I'm awful glad that Joe
liked a rumble in the Bronx but it's
between Effie and Mark for me and I
think that you know it was it was back
and forth of two nifty and Mark but if
he opened the door that mark then wisely
and smartly stepped through one if he
said you can't have a patriotic movie
without epic fight fights and big
speeches and mark correctly pointed out
there right before is nothing but that's
one for Marcus one for Mark Ellis the
epic fights and big speech rule
Daniel Radford oh man I hate when I have
to say I agree but I completely agree
although I the whole thing about how the
bad bugs gonna look like garbage but the
the really all the arguments about like
having something to fight for and having
that emotional connection got me and
then yeah that last that little zinger
about the epic epic battles and speeches
really got me mark so I gotta go at mark
Mark Ellis taking the point there you go
it is one push listen if I can change
and you can change John Cassian Eva
Braun van Gogh and mark if he yet to get
on the board question number three he's
yours brother
hey guys what movie character would
throw the best barbecue in honor of
fourth of July bbq's what movie
character best barbecue Mark Ellis all
right well in the interest of time I
will allow my fellow competitors to just
not wager an argument wants to hear my
answer because it's you're allowing them
the forfeit short everybody can get back
to their week mama clump from the Nutty
Professor it's the best person to throw
a barbecue because she makes the most
food she makes the most delicious food
if her family's any indication and on
Yuma barbecue it's not just about making
delicious food although that's a big
part of it's also about
having a family and it's also about
camaraderie and friendship and playful
jabs at each other and that's what the
Klump dinner scenes bring to the night
professor that's what's going to be
happening this barbecue how you're gonna
have some good old-fashioned family back
and forth it's gonna be hilarious
there's gonna be some some some emotions
gonna run high at the end of the day
we're all family you're gonna feel like
family when you join the Klumps a
barbecue is a lot more than just who can
grill the best food although I would put
mama Klump in that class she prepared
the food and she also prepared a family
environment that everybody can enjoin
you look at that dinner table in the
Nutty Professor or the buffet scenes and
the night professor to the Klumps it's
when you get to see a variety of
generations and people with different
ideals all coming together for the
common bond of food that's what a great
barbecue does
that's why mama Klump is the only
correct answer okay Mark Ellis mama
Thurman firm background to Joestar my
vote is Bilbo Baggins when junior
Tolkien created the hobbits
he wrote hobbits at the top of a piece
of paper and then the next line he wrote
was these [ __ ] can eat eating
and preparing good good as food is what
defines hobbits that's what they do all
these people do is get together for a
big-ass party get a bunch of food
together Bilbo Baggins if his birthday
is any indication that fourth of July
block party barbecue is going to be huge
it's gonna be ridiculous there's gonna
be tux party and there's gonna be proud
foots party and this thing is going to
be absolutely unforgettable the best
food in the Shire everybody's gonna be
smoking weed watching fireworks Bilbo
Baggins man nope no contest all right
Joe coming in with Bilbo iffy you know
as the only father on the panel I guess
I have to say I'm an expert on barbecues
and barbecues aren't just thrilling
barbecues aren't just over eating
barbecue is all about the atmosphere
barbecue is all about the host and what
the post is bringing to the table the
host needs to be flashy yet concern the
host needs to be able to grill that meat
and that host needs to have the best
grill and Technology of all so why not a
host with built-in grilling technology
why not Johnny Storm for 2005's
Fantastic Four
you got a man who's a showboat who would
love okay so anything this torch dizzy
okay this torch I would love more than
anything than to show off how much he
can grill
you got a man exuding with big dick
energy you got a man to not just give
you the best grilled foods you ever
tasted the best grill party you ever had
not only is he gonna have all the foods
he's gonna have all the drink and home
who has like like you know I'm actually
happy kicked us off with just saying you
were so I was so ready to believe that
you have the best pic and you do not
thank you mama cork farts too much she
set on fire before extra thank you so
the clumps of the family who comes to
the barbecue you like ah here they come
they already making plates they are
family who when you were a kid you're
like I might just stay in my room and
play video games
yeah and that's also have an uncanny
valley issue going and hanging out at a
barbecue at the Klumps I will not eat
once I noticed that all of them look
exactly like Eddie Murphy like all of
like that's a creepy barbecue this
barbecue takes a dark and sinister turn
when you realize that they might all be
just like clone from the same person or
what's going on here at this club
barbecue I'm very uncomfortable whereas
at Bilbo's place hospitality is key I'm
chillin I'm eatin some some some
barbecued that from some meat that was
flown in from from Gondor and and
Gannett his homey Gandalf is just
throwing off the best fireworks display
you've ever seen in your life
and you know you had me going but the
one thing the barbecue needs is good
music Hennessy to show ups in front of
FC look here's the real issue here is
that these two picks can contribute to a
good barbecue the Human Torch would be a
great grill master the grill master does
not disagree on that a barbecue ok human
towards person was probably gonna burn
the place down we know every 4th of July
you hear stories about people who have
fireworks that explode in their hands
and all of a sudden they're not as good
at the NFL anymore and then with no
stars picked here's the big problem yes
maybe Bill Bowes at ok host of a
barbecue if he's home what's the name of
the Hobbit movie and unexpected journey
he leaves his house parties weeks ok
Bilbo is not a reliable host I have
serious sanitary concerns about what
goes on in the Shire with those gross
feet that they never bother covering
with the clumps first of all if you're a
big argument against mama clump hosting
a barbecue is it she farts it's a
barbecue there's going to be gas passed
and it wasn't mama clump party it was
her husband and she'll just excuse him
to the other room do not attack mama
clump and blame all of the sins of the
clump family on mama clump mama clump is
hosting this barbecue she is the one
that is most suited because she cares
about family she cares about having a
good time she wants everybody well-fed
not everybody not just people who show
up first the clumps and by proxy mama
clump are the best overall barbecue
experience see the clumps are just all
about can you imagine just sitting at
that table while they all do it like
they're so like I'm glad they love each
other I'm glad they get along but you're
an outsider at that table you you you're
on you're not in their inside jokes
you're not in that rhythm you're not in
their banter you're an outsider you
don't feel welcome everybody feels
welcome at Bilbo Baggins barbecue you
guys it's kind of look the reason turkey
legs are good as hell at a Ren fest and
at Disney for a reason and Bilbo Baggins
place is just going to be barbecue
turkey legs for days it's going to be
amazing
look Human Torch yeah he's
made of fire but that doesn't mean he
can cook I know how to hold a lighter to
a spray paint can and make a [ __ ]
fireball that doesn't mean I can cook a
chicken yeah but see the thing about the
human torches that's why I've mentioned
that he's a showboat he's learned this
he's test this out
he isn't just gonna throw the party at
me like I guess I can do it now that
that boy like I said has big big energy
he has been planning this this is how
he's about to lay whoever comes down
he's inviting his crush along with all
his friends he's not going into this
just like a bumbling fool he's playing
this out now let me talk about your your
your world as a whole first of all this
is a world where people got invisible
rings people give out beasts that they
slice people at the table I'm not trying
to be eating ribs that's that's what
people say when things are not cool
everything's cool
yeah everything's cool at my mom's house
until my stepdad comes by then what
happens we don't know but we can't tell
anybody
weird thing that's happened at Bill
Bowes house is he leaves a little early
that's it
that's the worst thing and then
everybody just chills with their turkey
legs watching don't fireman when he
comes back when when does he come back
cuz who knows he just got sent on some
magical mission and now we're sitting
here ribs nobody nobody knows to go to
the grill and flip it that's burnt
that's burnt meat right there Club knows
how to go to a grill and flip it the
human torch can turn into fire that's
awesome how I have serious safety
concerns about both of these barbecue
hoes because human torch could have a
couple beers and all of a sudden he's
puff it up and down he can't control
himself and when we go to Middle earth
like if he said magic rings are involved
that make people all power hungry the
worst thing that would happen at a
Klumps barbecue is two family members
get into a shouting match the worst
thing that happens and a lord of the
rings' barbecue is it Sauron gets wind
of it sends his minions and the next
thing you know Hobbit death everywhere
that's a your Barbie correct you because
that is not the worst thing that can
happen at a Clemson barbecue what can
happen at Klumps barbecue is something
ready could come by and Uncle ready been
staring at Auntie tisha for a minute so
then now Uncle Rick gets drunk and I'm
teaching uncle Rainier throwing bows
what is mama club
characters in the film I'm speaking from
knowledge and truth buddy I'm speaking
from knowledge and if you need another
look at this chocolate in this you can
just look at it even more I'm all right
Wow barbecues Dan facts were there any
there were a couple actually going if
you can remember way back before this
round started Joe said though he's done
with the song no easy way out was quoted
and Joe said of the immortal words of
Stan Bush Robert temper actually yeah I
know that we got into cannon and
non-canon clump things however I believe
and I've tried to confirm as much as I
can through the clips of the movie that
I found while this this invitation was
going on while model of Klump did indeed
start the farting at the dinner table it
was not by herself farting she mentioned
getting her colon cleansed which then
led the rest of the family to begin
farting so I don't know if her
flatulence is necessarily what you worry
although it is a very flatulent family
no like yeah I know I cannot eclis farts
yes that was the question at hand here I
am the robert muller of deciding which
all right let's let's start with as far
as weighing in on the match Danielle
Radford oh my goodness okay all of these
were such fantastic arguments mercury
arguments were great but I have to say
as soon as you said emotions running
high I was like no that is literally why
I don't go home for Thanksgiving and the
food is great it's the best food I'll
ever have I will never be there anymore
I don't need to watch I don't need to
watch my relatives fight over things
that happened 20 years ago because
everyone got a little too liquored up so
I'm sorry mark I love you but that one
just kind of maybe that's personal I'm
gonna go ahead and count it
the well Baggins was great but I have to
say that if he when he mentioned which
mark kind of set him up for was that
Bilbo is never gonna be around and then
if he was like who gonna flip the meat
and I was like I was gonna flip the meat
who's already hired with troll money and
you know and I I do agree that like that
you know there's bad things that can
happen there there's bad things
happening over there Human Torch big dad
energy
I gotta go with if eating waterway all
right that's one for iffy
oh and so yeah three pretty cool
pictures of barbecues mark is really
selling me on that but they got him with
man look the clumps are gonna just clean
up do they're gonna have I think if he
said they're gonna have two plates
before this thing even started like I
hope I get a little mac and cheese
please please leave me a morsel of mac
and cheese and also know I mean is if
the farming is so epic if the farting is
so epic it's gonna bring down the room
that's shaving
here overeats
if he's now a father so his entire world
perspective has changed if he's if he's
defense made for good offense here
because I mean yeah the music at the
Middle Earth barbecue Thor the wack ass
flute for that flute and then yeah
wouldn't been the ring race oh there's
an unpleasant guest yeah yeah I got it
so I gotta go I gotta go if he ominous
gotta go if he if he gets the point and
that means we have a three-way tie so
yeah tiebreaker JT tiebreaker okay so
this will work a lot of speed round I
will ask the question first first answer
will go first second answer go second
third third and then you'll each get
twenty seconds starting with the first
person to answer and then after everyone
gets 20 we'll each get a ten second row
but and then Dan Danielle and myself
will decide who does not move on we will
weigh in on the third best answer of the
three and that person will sit out the
speed round here's the question y'all
ready for this
cease and desist great literally we just
got to see some decisions okay oh so
many great movie presidents so many
great
so many just a fourth of July in about
that but movie presidents aside what
movie character would make the all-time
worst US president what movie character
would make the worst president of all
time climber from Ghostbusters Slimer
Janos from Ghostbusters - Janos
Ghostbusters - gonna go with president
Camacho from idiocracy pres Camacho
Terry Crews idiocracy okay so we'll hear
from mark and then Joe and then if he
mark twenty seconds begin whenever you
speak well Solano would make the worst
US president because he's not a person
he's a disembodied spirit that floats
around in the only way he really
manifests in the physical world is to
drive cars erratically and eat hot dogs
so I think Slimer has no stamps on
foreign or domestic policy I think
Slimers a horrible leader for the rest
of us and I can't stress this enough out
he's naked he literally would be giving
naked hot ages Joe whenever you already
begin speaking twenty seconds I think
Slimers aggressive and he knows what he
wants and that makes a good leader
Janusz meanwhile is kind of spineless he
doesn't really he's not really able to
make his own decisions he's a he's a
yes-man to a larger sort of sort of evil
he'll just sort of bend over to whatever
you want him to do he can't make
decisions on his own he kidnapped a baby
once that's not a good look and and he
can't take hints when Dana's not into
him and his eyes glows sometime alright
if he twenty seconds begin whenever you
speak president Camacho would be the
worst president because out of all these
three he's the only one who could
actually run and probably win in this
climate and that's what makes him scary
he's gonna be basically doing everything
that we've had and just breaking down
every
thing I haven't really said words up
because it's just such a scary thought
but he's has the platform to win hang
ten second rebuttal slammer has no
political experience whatsoever at least
Camacho has that and y'know she actually
went through a bad experience but came
out better on the other side at the end
of ghostbusters 2 so he'll be a better
leader than Slimer going forward one
moment is not a complete character
change make Camacho a black guy that
loves guns could really bring together a
lot of communities in this country so
that sort of makes my solid leader but
again Janos kidnapped a baby one time
he's just he's very nebbish he doesn't
have confidence to be a public speaker
you know alright TV has a black guy who
loves gun and it does not unite us at
all and like I said come on she was the
only one who can actually be President
because he's the only human of the three
end point time all right let's start
with Dan Merle hmm I thought that the
non corporeality of marks choice might
might be used for or against Slimer but
it really was it was pretty even going
into the rebuttal round I I do feel like
I'm definitely going to do not eliminate
if he in my mind because I think that
the the only person that could actually
get elected is a pretty strong point and
I thought he were better the other
arguments well so if he goes through in
my mind and I believe that mark also
made a better rebuttal so my my non
point has my non point or do I give a
point your non point my non point goes
to Joe I would eliminate Joe from the
contentious Joe and you know what I'm
going to agree with Dan on that I felt
like yeah if he had a nice rebuttal
there as well and Mark was just like the
had the most passionate impactful answer
Joe well fought well played but we're
moving on to the speed round without you
sir let's all salute Joestar the real
American thank you all right American
argument for a long time yeah yeah I can
tell you have that one your back pocket
[Laughter]
that was a Danielle puzzle piece
okay so it is one one going into the
speed round and now it is anybody's game
mark iffy here we go gentlemen are you
ready you know the rules 20 seconds 20
seconds ten second ten second okay first
person to speak gets the energy to get
my shoes here we go first question of
the speed round
what movie character would you hire to
design your fireworks display Rocket
Raccoon Tony Stark Rocket Raccoon Tony
Stark if you spoke first 20 seconds
begin when you speak now Rocket Raccoon
would be the best because he's gonna do
whatever it takes for the best show
whether it be illegal whether it be
intergalactically illegal and he's gonna
go and find it and he's gonna go big
plus he already knows demolition pretty
well so I can trust that he's gonna have
the things that that really knock it out
the park make it boom make it zoom make
it Tony
an expert in explosives and aerodynamic
technology so Tony Stark is gonna be
able to pull off the best fireworks show
and we have actual evidence on celluloid
of Tony Stark doing that from the very
first Iron Man Tony Stark is a guy who
knows how to be innovative and in the
world of fireworks that makes your
display stand apart plus he knows
Earth's gravity a lot better than rocky
racoon time true but Iron Man one was a
long time ago and he gave that up that
was actually the whole plot of Iron Man
1 so he's probably gonna be rusty
meanwhile Rocket Raccoon is still
blowing stuff up even as friends
sometimes and it looks fun Rocket
Raccoon is gonna be a very dangerous
fireworks display and safety is key
Rocket Raccoon is good at collecting
guns not necessarily fireworks Tony
Stark has made fireworks go off at his
presentations he knows how to do it time
okay Wow yeah just as far as I think you
knocked him down with it being dangerous
and he's and Tony Stark knows the
Earth's gravity and you know the he
knows the planets oh yeah I'm gonna go
with mark on that Danielle radford I
love you if but you really mess yourself
up when you said that rocket was gonna
blow his friends up literally like the
only job you have as a fireman is play
no one cares if the firework doesn't go
off but if you blow someone up everyone
cares so you kind of made Mark's point
for him and then he drove it home I love
you babe
all right yes the firework doesn't go
off cuz it doesn't that kind of mean you
don't get what you came for do you care
about that more or about someone
straight-up being murdered yeah who is
it given those two options that are
just sayin damn like yeah what's better
oh we go home we went home afterwards
nothing happening we just had a drink or
our friends died
yeah Rocket Raccoon would be a much
better Statue of Liberty though would be
the best Statue of Liberty by the way
where's Detroit who won Marc Ellis going
in to question two of the speed round
here we go what movie creature should
replace the bald eagle as the icon of
America the owls of ga'hoole owls of
ga'hoole legend of the guardians who do
you pick
if he I deserve it
um you know what I'm going with Pikachu
from the Pokemon good alright pika pika
all right uh Mark Ellis spoke first 20
seconds begin when you speak now who'll
well you want something to recapture the
majestic flight of an eagle as your
representative and the Owls not only
capture that they also have the ability
to speak so they can actually say things
that are powerful and present and
relevant to our current times plus they
can soar through the air and they're
called
The Legend of it that they defend
wherever they are whether it's Google or
the United States of America
well flight would be nice owls or creepy
talking owls even more creepy Pikachu is
cute and he stands by his partner's side
in the face of evil which is what's more
American than that
that's the symbol we need who's gonna
stand there and even when you kind of
die and turn and rock your tears will be
brought will bring you back to the fight
so you can turn around and fight in
YouTube that's what mute that's what
Pikachu represents cute
let's party our no Ga'Hoole isn't
necessarily in America but I think
they're a better symbol for America than
a Japanese created thing that would be
the final nail in the coffin for a
Japanese take over America
what we want we want a bird that
represents freedom the owls of ga'hoole
on the long list of nations taking over
America Japan is very low on that list
so I might just start off with that
secondly like I said how's our creepy
those things can turn their heads all
the way around I don't even know why
it's right all right Wow Dan Merle
mm-hmm I did not realize there was an
impending Japanese invasion of you know
watch their YouTube channels decades ago
[Laughter]
I think if we just for the the the
passionate speech about friendship and
and and and even if you're defeated that
your your companions tears will bring
you back to life that's very inspiring
and rousing sentiment and I believe that
I I'm gonna side with history on this
okay Dan picks Pikachu Danielle - I
choose you yes that's my regiment um so
as great as the argument American thing
not Japanese thing is all it did was
remind me about the which I believe was
something you actually brought up
earlier and someone can fact check it
when they go back later which was at the
Statue of Liberty was the thing that was
brought to us by friends which was an
argument that was made literally earlier
in the show by one al
so it did remind me of that yeah so I
got to go I got to go with it me all
right we're all tied up at 2-2 this is a
great moment in sports question number
three of the speed round that was in
your album yeah yes what filmmaker what
filmmaker deserves to be on the hundred
dollar bill instead of that jerk Ben
Franklin who wasn't even a real
president that's what it says here
parentheses Steven Spielberg what
filmmaker should be on the hundred
dollar bill instead of founding father
Ben Franklin Steven Spielberg Steven
Spielberg if II just gotta take the best
one for the Gator okay Greta Gerwig
Greta Gerwig all right Steven Spielberg
Greta Gerwig Marc Ellis 20 seconds
represent the hundred dollar bill you
once somebody that has a storied history
in America and nobody as far as a
filmmaker represents that better than
perhaps Steven Spielberg who's made all
sorts of great movies smaller movies
that have a really heartfelt story huge
giant blockbusters that are beloved
throughout the generations and Steven
Spielberg's movies have made a lot of
hundred-dollar bills so I think it's
only fitting and natural he's the one on
it that is an amazing point I truly
believe it but I think if we're changing
the $100 bill now we have to really
capture something that is now and that
is the progressive state of America that
we're moving forward we're ever-changing
and just like the film industry I think
Greta Gerwig represents that that this
is going to change it is no longer there
gonna be just male-dominated we're gonna
stand stand by side no matter what other
race color creed we're gonna make good
movies I think if that was your impetus
for change $100 bill there's better
filmmakers out there to go with the ava
duvernay or patty Jenkins but if you
want the best filmmaker to represent the
best
means of currency and America Stevens
memory has the Linnaean camera I will
argue that you can make that point but
film is subjective so some people may
think Greta Gerwig is as good also she
has made the biggest impact and I think
in the past five years so that's why I
went with Greta Gerwig time all right
very debate school Wow yes well played
gentlemen both of you let's start with a
Daniel Radford I love this as I'm typing
it I'm like remembering I have all these
transcription skills don't like typing
as you're talking make me feel good
about myself which is why I love you um
this is really hard there were great
arguments from both of you I will say
that it was what was an exact title of
the round well here's the question what
filmmaker deserves to be on the $100
bill okay
Wow I have to say that Mike's argument
that if you are going marks are marks
sorry
many times we are literally bud than our
terrible person um I'm gonna say that
Mark's argument about how if you are
going to go with a female filmmaker
there are other better ones to go with I
do have to agree with so I've got to
give this one to mark most on the
arguments why do you act like you hate
it so much when you give you
experts experts call it Joestar syndrome
thing and they're like yeah if he I
thought you bit off a lot when you chose
Greta Gerwig but your argument really
opened my eyes and made me think damn if
he's making a point but I think mark I
don't know what that'd be de but I think
mark Perry there and took the point for
me so yeah mark you get that point would
send your Spielberg oh okay I think the
real revelation in that round is lon
Harris is apparent grudge against
Benjamin Franklin in the rain yeah not
hair is not the same amount of luck what
is he kite fly what's he got against I
noted bon vivant Ben Franklin number
four by the way this is game point for
Mark Ellis if he you need this to tie it
up and take it to a final question what
is the best movie ever made about a u.s.
president real or fictional okay best
movie about a u.s. president real or
fictional don't go with that one try to
get into people's heads you're gonna say
Dave Kevin Kline Kevin Kline your knee
Weaver
I'm gonna say Air Force one mm-hmm all
right
he was height man yeah all right we have
climb versus four day versus Air Force
one Mark Ellis spoke first 22nd begin
when you speak now well both these
movies are clearly their realm of
fiction but Dave is a great
representative of what America's best
ideals are that's why it's the best
movie about an American presidents
because Dave is guy who really comes
from nothing he happens to look like the
guy so all of a sudden he gets to sit in
the chair and he realizes it with this
power you can do good instead of bad and
he works his darkness using the skills
at his disposal to make that happen and
we get some good laughs along the way
the thing I like about Air Force one is
because you know I always thought ever
since I was a little kid what would it
be like if my president kicked ass and
therefore someone answered that question
I think that's what we need to see more
of I mean we got all the biopic s-- so
if we're gonna keep it fictional why
don't we have a kick-ass precedent like
president Camacho like I mentioned
earlier bring more kick-ass presidents
and that's that's my argument I think
the Air Force one's awesome but Air
Force one is an action movie that
happens I have a president in it where
the president and the president see in
the way that politics are run is the
central theme of date whereas it's just
a side character an Air Force one I mean
I felt like you said a lot of words to
describe boring movie where like Air
Force One it's just a tight ass movie
and yeah it doesn't follow politics
because that [ __ ] is boring what's tight
kicking somebody off a plane and saying
get off my plane Wow let's go with Dan
Merle the question I mean I will agree
that Air Force One is a tight ass movie
it's got the tightest bass of any I
don't think that's in question and I
don't want my decision to bring him on
that point having said that I've was it
mark made the more coherent argument
about why it tied into the presidency to
the country itself other than the fact
that Air Force one again is a tight ass
movie I'm gonna go for mark on all right
that's one for mark yeah I was a little
disappointed that no one picked the
correct answer frost/nixon
but the west side yeah very enjoyable
Franklin everywhere a kid becomes the
president like a blank check but yes his
first kid with Sinbad that would have
been a strong choice perhaps but yeah I
thought mark laid out just a a poignant
breakdown of what made Kevin Klein's
character and just thoughtful and
accessible and I really I really dug
your opening round I felt like nothing
superseded that afterwards so mark I
also give you the point mark Ellis takes
the day I would like to thank my
competitors here because America it's
all about good spirited competition
I love Joestar I love if the you guys
really you're talking about a
tight-assed movie of Air Force One these
guys two of the firmest buttocks you'll
ever feel that's true mark thank you so
much and Friday night Comic Con American
comedy company yes sir yeah very excited
to do that show with a lot of cool
special guests get tickets to marquel's
live.com from a coach mode hell yeah
Mark Ellis well fought a funny factual
well somewhat according to Dan and all
sorts of good stuff - background -
Joestar how thanks for having me
always a pleasure to walk five feet over
to the studio and in that suit can you
come around to the front show that way
yeah oh yeah you are so the dad to his
son show the kids literally as soon as
hit as soon as he's out of frame is when
his shorts end to get some good jokes
start cat batters so yeah
and I've been working on look it is
fourth of July guys all my arguments are
about community and step it up and so
this fourth of July do so my suggestion
is donate to Rice's it's the largest
nonprofit immigration legal service in
the country and if that's something
where you're like well there's all sorts
of other things why why this particular
issue oh you care about is hot hot
button things pick one pick something in
your community whether that's locally
nationally donate donate your time
donate money that's what this supposed
to be about excellent thank you sir if
he really funny and well fought today
tan close one go ahead and plug some oh
yeah so definitely if you ydy ify OS
right there now you can put that that a
handle on Instagram and Twitter I'll be
having a show at the dynasty typewriter
called afro funk which is going to be
July 12th at 10:00 p.m.
dynasty typewriter looking up on the
internet we're gonna have byron bowers
dulcis Sloan Opie alibi you and Maggie
Mae so it's gonna be a fun lineup we're
doing lots of stand-up and fun stuff
awesome yeah that's a super cool new
theater in Los Angeles and that sounds
excellent
thank you sir always great to have you
ah Dan Merle yes sir
oh thanks for being here any any
exciting news announcements upcoming
movies you're excited about oh wow
so so many of those things yeah
no just watch I feel like I leave it all
out on the field here watch this here on
screen junkies and screen junkies news
we're always covering the new stuff and
there is one coming out this weekend in
limited release mm-hmm sorry to bother
you is playing near you I know there I'm
not sure what the rollout strategy is
but
I will guarantee you one thing it's
going to be the most unique movie you
see this year and that makes it worth a
watch no matter what in my book so if
it's playing around you and you like to
be challenged by movies and you like to
see something different and unique go
see star to bother you if it's playing
near you because you yeah to top my list
I can't wait to see it 100% I definitely
agree yeah thanks Dan Danielle Radford
hello I'm as per usual follow me on the
social is on Twitter I'm just in your
Radford on insta I am Danielle
underscore Radford
please keep Lea guys have been really
into bubble and that has been like super
nice and cool so yeah I keep keep
watching bubble and I'm gonna I'm
working on some stuff but hopefully
she'll be coming out so yeah if you keep
on my social medias you can keep up with
all of the things that I am trying to
work on excellent Danielle thank you as
always
corgis for life and I want to thank I
want to thank you for watching yes you
can find me on Instagram and Twitter at
Hal Rudnick and yeah I really appreciate
joestar's message that really touched me
I'll second that and say think of people
who are less fortunate I mean regardless
of your situation there's always someone
that's got it worse and if you could
give a little something man that I don't
think we say that enough so I really
appreciate that I hope you had a great
Independence Day in America and outside
of them are
and thanks again for watching movie
fights see you next time bye bye
you